aquí hay unas cotizaciones de subastas
que están mostradas en cnn.com y mi
objetivo aquí es que ustedes se
familiaricen con estas cotizaciones para
que sepan qué es lo que están viendo y
esas opciones se categorizan dependiendo
de su fecha de expiración esas opciones
que estoy mostrando aquí expiran en
abril del 2011 y las opciones usualmente
expiran en el tercer viernes de cada mes
o para ser exactos el tercer viernes del
mes es el último en el que se puede
comerciar con estas opciones ya que
oficialmente terminan el sábado estas
son acciones de ge que están cotizadas a
18 dólares con 95 centavos y la forma en
que se muestran o se despliegan en este
sitio web tiende a ser como es en la
mayoría de este tipo de sitios y aquí
podemos ver que de un lado están los
precios de rescate y en el otro están
las opciones de venta por supuesto que
esto se refiere a lo de general electric
y los precios de compra de acciones
están mostrando de menor a mayor en la
primera columna tenemos el símbolo de
esta acción en particular este es el
último precio de negociación esto indica
cuánto ha cambiado
estos han sido los precios de
negociación más pequeños y más altos
durante el día esto indica cuántas
acciones se han vendido ese día y esto
del interés abierto quizá sea algo que
ustedes no están muy familiarizados si
solo vemos las cotizaciones de acciones
básicamente eso se refiere a cuántos
contratos de opciones abiertas hay en
existencia por ejemplo aquí nos dice que
hay 399 opciones de precio de rescate
abierto con una presión de compra de
acciones de 14 dólares y con una fecha
de caducidad de abril del 2011 en
general electric y nos dice que ninguno
de sus 399 opciones de precio de rescate
abierto han sido comerciales ese día si
alguien compra una acción de las 399
este valor cambiará a 398 y si alguien
publica una nueva acción ese número
ofrecerá a 400 las acciones también
conocidas como dentro del dinero se
listan en este color azul clarito como
el precio de compra de acciones en estos
casos es menor a lo que vemos aquí como
precio de la acción si tenemos un precio
de rescate abierto de 17 dólares
que nos da el derecho de comprar que por
17 dólares y lo ejercemos el día de hoy
lo compramos a 17 y podemos venderlo
inmediatamente a 1895 por lo que
tendríamos una ganancia inmediata de 1
con 95 y pueden ver aquí que la opción
de comprarla está un poquito más arriba
de esto y eso es porque tienen la
opcionalidad es decir definitivamente
pueden ganar un dólar con 95 centavos en
este momento pero tienen la opción de
ganar un poco más si esperan a la fecha
de cierre del tercer viernes de abril
del 2011 y el único riesgo que corren es
puedes perder el precio que pagaron por
esta acción y podemos ver que las
opciones que tienen su presión mayor al
precio actual de la acción si yo tuviera
una opción de rescate que valiera 20
dólares o un precio de ejercicio de 20
dólares eso significa que podría
venderla en el mercado en este momento
viendo que el precio de la acción el día
de hoy está a 18 95 y venderla de
inmediato por 20 dólares teniendo
una ganancia de un dólar con cinco
centavos y podemos ver que en la
negociación de venta más reciente fue de
uno con cuarenta debido a la
opcionalidad